Thanks pick you up come in Game four
returning after a I am create cocoa and
my thesis arises from the study of video
games a topic near and dear to my heart
is long hair and game player this is my
latest step in my journey makes my hobby
my academic work um and this step has
been a particularly blush one as this
product is manifested and good fortune
to what now looms here um the last time
I perfected a comical word for my
undergrad pieces uh sort of comfortable
I help needed to justify why descending
games or why anyone would study games
but now I have been embedded you can
communities during the set or this one
on which even though so you can also be
games recognize them as a medium that
like those who turns out the other
presentations today is a really rich
place for considering that artifacts
that people spend hours weeks ears and
gloves creating and zebra so um with
that I will be devolved through this
basis including its goals saying
theories the theoretical foundations
upon the breasts and illustrations of my
analyses um accompanying call this our
images games that have led me here in an
inspirational first examples of in my
work of past and present on and likely
future as well I'm not all the games
pictured close discussed as this one but
rather than light instead of reading on
the visual depictions of my research
site in games in some cases a break foil
to the rather bored dark and dreary
aspects that I'm critiquing in that
Beijing site great so um as I've
mentioned I'm not here to justify the
seven games in creating trade with
authority in the poetics of art and film
critics and in way to teach of the words
of the industry's not tours to tackle
those mainstays of opinion condition for
loss well um support so artistic merit
games has been measuring coffee table
books engineers like always with the our
commitments such beautiful images
manifestations of human emotion only be
the projects I've been hard on part with
those of the longer history I'll toast
certainly not always the case so
obtained the most publicly visible parts
and game criticism Lincoln's journalism
these poignant moments beautiful
expressions happen in the person games
that are most recognizable from other
media the story in the audio visual
assets hello Bert crucially the medium
also at least in most cases requires
player whose interaction shape how the
game unfolds and without which the
game's not proceed thus the ways in
which the player is able to interact
with these a with the system of game in
our a defining part of the potential
experiences of a game this is more often
go to entreated non-mainstream factor in
Game criticism but it's not uncommon for
this treatment to operate to the
language and current aesthetics of
software design for example beating game
designs found in simplicity and clarity
or use use and can be separated from the
story or art assets where beauty may
instead be found in emotional complexity
or diatonic twists of turns or the
blending of many lines and colors and
forms or sounds for that separation
between game design and game stories and
art seems tenuous t what if I'm more
interesting than their separation is
instead what if for you Liz foot pack
real calls the interplay between Wilson
fiction that is I am interesting how a
game to roll some fiction interact with
and infect each other especially if not
exclusively where they can flex and may
present cleaning making opportunities
and discordant with the others to
introduce my research questions and my
topic of study and respects fire to play
around Quincy effects and beauty to be
found in games those popular method
measures the mediums artistic merit how
to swing reads in the literary theory
sense a game and presents such beautiful
advents and either it's real narrative
or rules windows need plates or colleges
one rule read rules that consistently
complete with particular games
narratives even when the latter are
being created the employment and
reflective of risk of social
feels indeed games fiction umbrella
building increasingly contributed really
interesting embroidered sheets of social
systems like gender race class politics
organized religion support yet what
happens to these critiques or messages
when they game's rules instead model
problematic aspects of these social
systems which may then be influenced in
several games or even a whole genre and
considering how one must treat both the
games real sensation in order to
understand my head you play most
importantly um most importantly our
games rules a narrative actually a
separate Bowl as a game room for example
might have one thing this project
identifies an investigation particular
site in which these conditions exist a
site I name or enter a warm interaction
which I will define presently in order
to reach an agreed on your standing of
how represented representation functions
in the overlap between games rules and
fictions I ain't analyze how horn
interactions are reflected in games
rules also knows their mechanics and how
those mechanics the reproduced
problematic schema of interpersonal
interaction emotionality and gender even
when those mechanics re-themed within
socially innovative or otherwise your
boarding narratives in the worlds but
first there is a lot going over there so
I pull out a key turns to specify what i
mean by each warden interaction is term
I'd point for my research site which is
just one aspect of how a player
character might interact with other
characters in the game a process which
is paramount that inactivate creates the
red or plays text of a game in warm
interaction I refer to interactions of
positive accounts or ones that rely on
the heavier side at night warm as
informant buzzing dealings um those
interactions are actualized in game
mechanics as actualizing game mechanics
are take actions taken in a cooperative
spirit namely you're taking in the
building and friendly or romantic
relationships both our games those who
contested training games studies here at
use mobility cards quite useful text
defining game mechanics to do just that
I game mechanics our methods and folks
by agents designed for interaction with
the game state ie the ways in which a
player is able to affect what happens in
the game usually mediated through a
controller or a similar device mechanics
which I also discusses game rules game
systems for procedural votes place you
know terms them personally hide some key
differences for the same threatening are
the system through which game design and
creator side effects gameplay with
marriage site so then what is it game
narrative Europa have already mentioned
um discuss this games fiction as
narrated by way of several definitions
from the act and delivery of story
chronologies architectural chronologies
and or prescribed fence themes victual
worlds and a process of meaning you'll
collaboration on fictional worlds ism
particular interest is that idea knowing
something else whereas world building
includes most creative storytelling and
story interpretation that are well
suited to the importances design
archetypes and thirdly nurses of digital
games those modes include at games
graphics such visual information is
found the portal information text
written the information cutscenes which
are fill my trips that do not allow for
or left for more limited period with
like a quick tankmen paratext the
objects materials around being such as
its title and a or subtitle packaging
written game guides like manuals bad
discussions media coverage under a hat
texting tactile information particularly
a controller vibration wheels definition
be simple unless like oddest with
certain actions games but the kind of
hectic side can also potentially include
the more internal field is healthy a
meeting devices like controllers um
rules and systemic information complete
and players contribution on time ever I
Gordon kya is model which is shown here
with your other small text um presents
game narrative as realms player
involvement which works in six mentions
the aesthetic avatar control spatial or
learnings shared interaction between
characters players narrative which are
free spirited and written out effective
drama and like emotional arts including
rules and constraints these dimensions
occur on two levels or faces the
microbes specific choices management
within particular sessions of a game
experience with the lighter in macro
which is a lasting impression of the
overall game experience so game
narrative is multifaceted place and has
strong from collapsed k mechanics but
not always the Prophet I in practice so
before jumping into my samples of a
leader heard name on my theory I in
studies revenue for Eastleigh
interdisciplinary often locating and
scholars and other disciplines
departments like this one so my main
fields of reference or was obviously
game studies and media studies but with
my emphasis on social critique
especially gender family studies also
undergirds my work he is dismal DS as
well as methodologies and takis study
those main fields also overlap in
subfields like emotional effects studies
performance studies which I've used
before in linking I gameplay with
religious practice and cultural arid
area studies particularly in my case
Japanese study says many of the games I
work with for creating Japan so the book
shown here at Catherine sisters how
BIG's move us emotions by design is
quite new published in the last few
weeks in fact uh with plenty of
journalistic coverage to accompany that
I bring that up to know where the
conversation on games and motion it's at
the moment in both eight studies from
with the book comes and public
perceptions of games which has been
referenced and covered in the book is
this jared cities the ways in which game
designers have set up possibility of
emotional experiences in games
particularly in cans my work notes that
this is the case and assumes that games
can be our and have for some time acted
as size for mobile experiences then it
pushes a Bigfoot further as games do
bleep us
what sorts of things are they moving us
towards and are the messages that game
design sense aligning with messages that
game derrieres present so I've tackled
those questions through a structural
analysis kind of semiotic text based
analysis that made a been made famous by
umberto eco and women bartending too
good on structural analysis allows me to
come to the massive complex texts that
games can be to find patterns that I can
then analyze in one level on how about
Ted and works in specific texture game
and then critique a particular on his
other how it works an aggregated across
text though I can find an image of him
smoking if for Yul's work as mentioned
has also been formative in my sampling
and finding what kinds of hadrons I can
study normally these theories are all
European white guys which somewhat
clashes with the feminist epistemology
is mentioned thus I also chose Diane
park who is John watch the Ducks such
literary filmic methods to the studying
games as well as with many many other
women in non by earning boats and people
color from study games um it's there's
at least one in this department um so q2
isn't ethnology present in my pieces but
to my other theory come from social
scientific disciplines where women are
doing work on those to play games very
much including women as I'm interesting
house which were compared on text based
work you're respecting a social
scientific words ethnological strengths
and limitations of mine are matters and
that I come to my analysis returning to
warn interaction caretaking ass
illustrate in two ways healing and
protection um healing too has two forms
one more ethereal and one more fiscal in
these images we see women from three
different games of the same role playing
game series upon a c10 four and 14
demonstrating white or cured of magic
which they drop on door to restore
health
the form of depletable hit points in
disabling the afflictions like being
poisoned here we see what kinloch
healing looks like with male characters
into action games smell years all of
three and killer seven different sites
have recovered or called upon the
medical and business like cleaning up of
death the text here synthetic version is
a painter and he goes into Reese dead
bodies in order to make noise it's
cooking um but although the character
shown here are not so nearly different
from those in the previous slide as the
protagonist in one character once
several that are at the players beckon
call on the women call upon magic
protagonist party member um the women
call upon magic learned through
emotional work overtime mastering skills
through tending to others for the
purpose of better tended to others the
men however um 10 to themselves snake or
dead others your skill seemingly mates
then I made available to the player
early in the game without having to
build such skills through your gameplay
on the other side of this caretaking
point is protection which very often
takes physical form unions most visible
is actually adventure games escort
missions in which the player characters
seemed responsible for the safety of a
non prepared here the player loses by
the character is killed or otherwise
becomes not own areas such as a
kidnapped by banks here to Leon of
Resident Evil 4 extracts the American
presidents daughter ashley is affair
from the zombie infested some European
Alliance um in some parts of the game
which say have typical combat situations
the player is given of action to tell
Ashley tweet in some kind of completely
place container as Leon the player
character trots off to dispose of
zombies here the boi eco leads your de
around the castle solving puzzles to aid
their escape whilst fighting off shadow
beings
up there it's tempting to drag your de
into their shadow holes one of the
buttons on the players controller is
mapped to allow the player to call out
to your de centering the median camera
on her and to hold your hand if she was
close enough you're then Ashley both
Catholic bad habit wandering off towards
enemy ports so that a player character
must come a christie brinkley on that
narrative obligations professional for
ego is personal he feels compelled to
help ordinarily for both the both
protection is an often enjoy beauty of
physically minding keeping vigil psycho
and destroy him threats to a female
character who has little understanding
of what to do to mitigate your own
suffering let alone protect yourself you
are the wind at my back and the sword at
my side together my love we shall build
a peaceful world just you and me
energetics of love and friendship here
Crom from Fire Emblem awakening
confesses his love for a female trainer
character the game presents a choice and
gender although this confession scene is
all the trappings of an adorable love
story sparkles and soft music and
honeyed words the way that that love
story comes to pass is less meat cute
and wornall teristic blending together
being together it means fighting better
in many games with such mechanics for
building romantic and friendly
relationships the template works like
this the player character has a choice
of potential of objects the player
character initiates courtship the time
spent with goods giving two or number
and nice playing alongside the chosen
love objects the loved object falls in
love with the player character and the
loved object produces some sort of
fennekin fairy in fire emblem that
beneficent child which note that her
normativity a a narrative of
reproductive value um
is a powerful character who can then
neither through dick into the players
army friendships don't produce children
but they do make friends Thunder
fighting together thus romantic and
friendly relationships can be written as
the perfect sites performed interactions
where both parties aren't happy and
healthy and they're caring for one
another but fair is implemented in
gameplay as wait to make clear
characters more powerful in their
martial pursuits as we move towards
conclusions I know I earlier mentioned
qualify c14 shining in here which is an
MMORPG I magically multiplayer online
role-playing game in that game and once
liked it I need my analytical results
them um players are able to customize
their character more deeply than in most
single-player games and often have a
fair amount of choice of patrol the
Planning Group their roles to choose
from usually take one in three forms
which create a group dynamic that
balances rules so that each player has a
particular functions filled through
their labors there is the tape of the
Protectorate of a group who draws he
keeps and me attention the DPS damage
per second whose job is Samantha
maximize how much damage is being done
than enemy which can only be done then
not being killed by seven me and the
healer can make sure the tank and
everyone else stays alive although
promotional materials like the image
myself of showed earlier on the january
of such rules is add my analysis found
magnetic party putting to the protectors
in some extent energy damage yet as
these roles are filled by people who
customize their characters the gendering
of these rules berries in game so that
my small female character concepts a
tank with a great acts as well as any
big tycoon unlike single-player games
MMO creators place greater emphasis on
signing social experiences for the
Messier mix of desires of actual people
whose desires make out alive with the
boxes into which their gender mixed
orphan which is great and could
potentially be a model for lessening our
usual imitating gender roles in some of
your aims and this leads me to my
conclusions though ways to move James
can forward effective
experiences are unique to the medium but
unique aspects are often not the ones
allowing for positive and personal
effect yet games are at cause it's still
an effective medium one I could do with
further exploration pal effects can be
experienced with in games and how game
designed and narrative can strengthen
each other rather than plate also
analyzing games this text is tricking
undertaking one that is necessarily
interdisciplinary luckily so this is
also a mercenary so if textual
approaches would they have much to gain
from relying on that aspect for critical
working future especially for social
driven texts like mmos or for offering
design alternatives for problematic
models I hope to be amongst the game
scholars doing that work in future but
for now thank you for letting me share
review system haga yes um I with for
example if when you're looking at and
then you mentioned that police reach
gender or the message desires of real
design you were sort of generally
recently my question is um except our it
can be both fit to like cinnamon and of
those do you see that generates
whimpering isn't that the designers are
actually shooting operate outside foods
conventions or employers wording for
conventions hey didn't get in animals
right oh so savvy hates me to all mmos
but how facing 14 is really where I have
most of my mo experience though there
has been significant sum all around
Enzo's um so from my experience some of
the things that might limit the
relationship between gender and taking
strict rules things like stats like
you set up email very early if she were
built to have like the restraint so we
can 24 sort of thing then she wouldn't
be a big choice for a concern soon the
dgs rooms but that doesn't seem to be a
case in holidays to 14 it is like with
emily minor and usually gets move out as
soon as you start playing um so it's
fairly building thinking that players
can kind of do whatever they want around
that especially at this game where you
can take up any class at any time so you
can experiment with what you like and
try to find a style that fits um
sometimes uh I have actually noticed a
pattern in game that you tend to see a
lot of a big buting accidents in small
women on we looking stays for healing um
and that a lot of these characters ok
I'll despite a wealth of skin color
options I don't have any like formal
data on that but i think it is you're
really missing avenue to see you know
how those character creation systems are
damaged yes so that's Roy different
names referenced here you can see is in
terms of protection
give up on them talking about Oh
mechanics are in bed with
representations of office um we're so
we're some examples that you have or you
can take me to those things you
mentioned here that the gameplay is not
structured so there is the game journey
which is kind also some went towards
them outside in that um uh interacting
with other characters that gave usually
that character is going to be a player
character and realized and then popped
into your umbrella knee don't know
anything about my character except for
the length of their scarf which is an
indicator kind of how much they've
played um and there isn't actually all
that much in terms of direct interaction
that you can do with another player or
injury I'll except for like walk and so
often what has been seeing in that game
is that I say like a character bowl on
Stark will pop into the novices game and
lead them to places where they can make
their stock for stark longer and there's
little room for enacting violence that
there's not really much that you can do
in order to eat mess with another player
barriers that's I have an interesting
one um uh yeah I'd have to do some of it
making in order to build Yannick but
your name is stuck my head in
a sort of little bit following up on
chores question so if you you have done
a very sharp analysis on the embedded
problems around warm interaction in the
sort of dominating existing sphere of
games but you're sort of also hinting at
there being some kind of promise
embedded in the concept of warm
interaction as well so I just wanted to
hear if you have some idea what is the
can warm interaction help us help
something or foil something or what what
is the power of the ones that that you
see it as a problem ah I mean it's mr.
Kent gets @ % book and thinking to um
kind of like yeah these kind of social
intimate interaction games that are
seeing less to elect lady business
spaces or at least in mobile rather than
Council spaces so i think i mean the the
hope i think would be um working on a
space for an empathy is a practical
skill um in a game world um that I'm
even one would hope that if there are
many representations of that possibility
that then that becomes more the dominant
language then finds over other people
make it so
thank you
you